yeah and then they're including David
Copperfield David Copperfield he
probably made those girls go away dude
probably made him disappear is that what
you're going to
say David Copa field you know what I'm
saying oh there you go uh Les Wexner who
founded Victoria
[Music]
Secret so the following video um was
submitted by Anthony Lee
okay you submit videos to Steve no I
didn't know we could do that bro he was
no remember when I put on all all the
Articles and he jacked them yeah yeah
yeah and uh hey you're welcome dude you
know you want to talk about what I did
for you a couple couple times yeah tell
them happy to do it happy happy still
holding on to it still holding on I will
you know I will so check this out no PVP
okay so was Stephen Hawkins a a super
per I heard I heard a lot of rumors
there's an interesting couple of rumors
that this guy so one of the rumors that
Anthony Lee told us about was that he
liked to watch like uh small little
people Anthony's favorite do math
problems he called them midgets he
called [__] midgets writing math
problems on a board that was too short
is that a is that a meme i s dude that's
literally a [__] Tik Tok this guy
sends me yeah no that's that it's
because we're supposed to talk about the
news before we present it to our our
listeners out here because we're
dedicated News host so is that real or
is that fake okay so you're supposed to
ask all the questions you ask all the
questions let me just put this into
context for everybody in case you don't
know Anthony got framed um there there's
an image going around about Stephen
Hawkins uh and they basically say
talking to one of the Epstein victims
did Jeffrey ever talk to you about
Steven Hawkins proclivities and the
respondent says yes he liked watching
quote undressed midgets solve complex
equations on two high up on a two high
up chalkboard I saw that paper too yeah
it's a document and it was highlighted
it this is from a deposition that
someone actually said un like a
disposition yeah not just that
right [__] me not just that it's okay
this video is it'll be out of order so
it won't matter yeah you're safe you're
safe from call back yeah you're safe
completely
safe um the other um thing that's going
around right now is official documents
about Jimmy Kimel oh right but he denied
yeah didn't he deny a Rogers there's a
document that's on Twitter so his name
wasn't even on it there's a there's a
couple documents on Twitter that had
that included his name actually are they
fake yes and all this is fake actually
oh the stepen Hawkings oh I was wishing
that was real oh that was fake no that
was so funny but we could edit this part
of the video out and then people could
just think it's real and we you know why
it's so believable cuz you just feel
like man I don't know if this
[__] be getting [__] at a
healthy schedule so he might be a freak
what well what about him having underage
orgies Is that real that was all part of
this thing that's not real
oh so Stephen hacky has nothing to do
with Epstein stuff nothing to do with
Epstein stuff so his name was never
mentioned huh um so you think EP wants
to hang out with [__] stepen Hawk
here where here's something that we know
wait explain this to me then explain
this here's something that we know
fine in 2006 few months before Epstein
was charged with multiple accounts of
unlawful sex with a minor Hawking was
one of the many scientists who attended
a 5-day conference in the Caribbean
island funded by Epstein and he is in
multiple pictures from that event but
that does not mean he was on the island
does not mean he was associated with cuz
F funded a shitload of things correct
get he was all over the place taking
pictures with all kinds of people but
people are doing this thing where any
picture that he's in with anybody
they're like that's another guy and
another one yeah yeah yeah cuz like that
was his main game right EP was going out
giving some money here shmoozing here
hey come hang out plus when Epstein's
taking a picture with like one of us say
yeah you know we can actually do
something about it Stephen Hawkin could
have just sit there that's all sit there
he's looking down left you but actually
he's he's a very likely suspect cuz
who's sucking his dick um you think he's
in again his dick sucked had he had a
chick he had a wife really yeah he
actually dumped his wife got with a
hotter nurse oh really I have credible
Source here well there's a [__]
groupy for everything that talks about
it um that talks about situations like
this just to hang out with Steven
Hawking just Oh Yes W nice day to hang
out with
me they say he goes to strip clubs
that's wild yeah laptop
Dance Now for me now work it girl take
me to the event
horizon there we go now what a great
idea to have fun now you know I want it
now don't sit on the
keybard delete delete delete delete so
I'm just saying is good cancel him
cancel him get rid of him I like that
that that's been going around too and
people are like Robin's trying to warn
everybody it's like yeah I know Robin's
making a joke you literal as [__]
you're so literal why are you so literal
he's doing bits about it I feel like
these guys actually make it worse cuz
then they make it it's like now it's
crackpot [__] no it is really that was
for Series XM series serious exactly
that's not a stand up serious yeah he's
trying to warn everybody folks yeah uh
Kimmel's name not in the documents at
all like you said there's a bunch of
fake [__] on Twitter about how do you
feel about Kimmel how do I feel about K
personally yeah I think he's the
best yeah one of the great comedians of
our time um Steve was the only one that
believed in him when he was getting
cancelled Steve was the only one like
see you guys [__] don't [__] follow
the trends and the rumors he's innocent
that's why he's here to debunk the
rumors exonerate the man we had to
change all Steve day for this I defend
all Stevens as well I defend all Stevens
Jimmy Kimmel support week on JK
especially when Jimmy Kimmel was
Shilling out the freaking vaccines Steve
was the one that was like you got to
listen to Jimmy we all got to get
vaccinated
yep you want who wants to go around the
room about the Vex anyone want to go
around the room I think you should
probably get another booster Maybe on my
10th one thank you U me
too hopefully hopefully we get paid for
that thanks for requiring it guys for
JK hey I just wanted to keep you guys
safe all right yeah yeah well excuse me
for following the law we got a flat in
the curve voice so another bunch of
celebrities that are falsely accused so
far are Elon Tom Hanks and Oprah what
about Chris Tucker yo I think that one
uh I think that one's a little more sus
yeah that's what everyone keeps saying
why why is that one sus that he was like
really into little he was actually named
in one of the depositions we don't know
if it's completely legit well I thought
he was on the flight flight logs so
there's a difference between flight log
and then um the deposition names but
then they're they're also saying well
the when you know when the first one
came out y so Bill Clinton and Trump was
named right but the but the one for
Trump was like have you seen him no I
didn't see him and that was it yeah yeah
and then the second one that came out it
was the one recently saying he's biting
on nipples and [__]
yeah which sounds okay yeah it's like
look we we all buy who's not a nipple
buyer yeah come on that's normal but the
way people thought Jimmy Kimmel was
involved is because um it's funny we
have a David Goes to uh Adam Perry
Lang's uh popups he's like a massively
good talented barbecue masterart soda
Bart Bart Bart loves little kids like
Adam I'm just kidding but um wow that's
what everyone was saying Joe was trying
to warn
us cuz Adam Adam Perry Ling and um Jimmy
Kimmel had a restaurant together so
that's how they're connecting it right
cuz cuz when um Adam was in the whole
list they're like saying like he's he's
just a [__] he's a [__] pedophile
it's like but he was the help so it's
like that means the ma that means the
gardener that means the everybody
involved yeah is is wrong like I don't
know that's like what they tried to do
with Michael Jackson's estate remember
they tried to get everybody that was
working like guilty for allowing things
to happen but they're just like I'm just
cutting grass bro like what the [__] so
was Michael right and and with in the
Chris Tucker I thought there was no
grass to be cut yeah there wasn't no
where are we going with that guys I'm
following your lead yeah you submitted
the article you submitted the article
You're The Mastermind he's innocent
can't can't
upute hey nice he's innocent so uh with
Chris Tucker right mhm definitely
Clinton definitely Kevin spy definitely
Chris Tucker um as far as like named in
connection with who went with him on the
plane but Clinton's like 50 times like
70 times or some [__] right but that
doesn't mean that we know that they were
[__] on kids or anything like that
also like I'm going to go to Six Flags
not ride
Viper Robert Kennedy's former wife I
don't know they R they rode too yeah so
like it's hard to tell like did everyone
who rode the plane you know go to the
island and and and do all this [__] or
was it that he was just lending this
[__] out cuz I heard that's what they
all do like they all go oh you're going
to La let me jump in your plane yep so
yeah and Chris Tucker was apparently on
a one of those five-day trips that
Epstein did often as well where they
went to Africa and like Epstein was
there too like but that doesn't mean we
know that imagine imagine this [__]
sadistic forethought of being like when
these flight logs potentially one day
get discovered the best way to cushion
the confusion is to just get as many
people on these things as possible so
let's just like offer flights left and
right just like try to try to see tempt
them right maybe it's like getting a
bunch of fingerprints on the same gun
yeah so no one knows who shot it cuz you
just know that you're doing something so
ridiculous the best way to kind of
protect yourself is to get everyone in
now we're really glass onioning there
was a a scientist that that was talking
about like how he came encounter with
Epstein and he was saying like EP was
like notoriously known to just come to
these events and be a a philanthropist
and like give hell of money to Charities
and all this stuff so that was like his
way in to getting around famous people
powerful people all that cuz those
events you have like Nobel Peace Prize
winners you have politicians you have
all kinds of people coming through so
I'm like maybe that was his way in that
was he that's that was his bad does
anything happen to like you know when
let's say somebody puts out a fake
document making Jimmy Kimel or Oprah
look like this do they ever Trace these
people down and like who started the
yeah cuz that's a massive crime isn't it
yeah like defamation that's [__] up
that's huge so um Chris Tucker right in
in his case he also um based on what
just happened with this judge who just
released a bunch of information that's
white Tucker's name is now in there it
was in there about the fight logs before
but now we know that he also allegedly
visited the island per US District Judge
Loretta presca releasing these names as
part of the settlement involving
Virginia Guffy against Epstein and gain
Maxwell oo so it's someone's willing to
say that he was there he at theow that's
what yeah and then they're including
David Copperfield David Copperfield he
probably made those girls go away dude
probably man disappears that you going
to say
[Laughter]
Tigers David CA you know what I'm saying
oh there you go there we go whoa uh Les
Wexner who founded Victoria's Secret oh
yeah that was like his homie yeah um
Nobel Laur Lawrence Krauss nobody
cares and Naomi Campbell Naomi Campbell
is a big name model big name big name so
yeah those are those have been mentioned
in the list of guests who visited the
island Tucker has yet to respond got to
be like when you think about it if you
got an island like this there's got to
be way more women than men on it to get
that ratio to get guys to go yeah so you
think there'd be like way more women
speaking up you think what if it's way
more what if it's way more innocent then
then we think like what if it's like a
way for guys to just go get away from
their wives so they can like smoke
cigarettes and complain just playing
with Lincoln Logs and Tinker Toys yeah
it's like that Meme it's like what they
think the boys are doing it's like all
they think they're dling
but what the boys are doing and it's
like you know they're riding midgets and
who are pretending to be Dolphins what
you what the [__] like there's like yeah
there's the one you'd love this one shut
the [__] up he already knows it yeah
yeah there's this one where these guys
are diving into a pool first um you know
the guys dive in the pool and then the
little guys dive in the pool and the
little guys are riding the big guys who
are pretending to be Dolphins yeah oh
it's that okay yeah it's yeah which is
acceptable that way the other way is
[__] that' be messed
up yeah be it wouldn't be buyant yeah
real bottom head it's not ethics it's
buoyancy yeah it's it's offensive to
people who it's just pure sky but I
wonder if like you know when you commit
a crime like let's say let's say you had
you committed defamation at a million
dooll level then the platform is able to
turn over IP addresses to the
investigators because the crime is so
high it almost seems like you're [__]
yourself by releasing these fake
documents like massively I I mean talk
about a good SC up right like a good I I
think someone who who used to do
disinformation for like one of the big
intelligence agencies I think CIA or
maybe mad they said there one of the the
best way you do a disinformation
campaigns released some true stuff with
some completely oh okay I yeah wow CNN
is really good at that so are we
mhm DUS King news SC ful Bo is a brand
just kidding news is the man of smart
people the people of just kidding news
careful boys they are very smart just
King news the number one podcast in the
[Music]
world
oh